♪ When will my reflection show ♪
♪ Who I am inside ♪
(upbeat music)
- My name is Joy Taney.
I've been a professional body painter
for two and a half years, and a professional artist for six.
- Hey guys, I'm Jade.
Today I'm gonna paint Clark and I suck at painting
but I get to paint my buddy today, so let's do this shit!
- My name is Clark and today I will be the canvas.
Let's get painting.
(Beethoven's Symphony No. 5)
- 30 minutes?
- You think I can stand still for 30 minutes?
- You can do it?
- Nah, I think I could try.
^- I can't wait to see.
(Beethoven's Symphony No. 5)
- Normally, this is the part where I talk shit,
but I know Joy's gonna kick my ass.
- Y'all ready to get painting?
- Let's do this.
- Let's go!
- This is fun, Clark.
I never though I'd have so much fun painting your belly.
(upbeat electronic music)
- Ooh!
- Does that tickle?
Did I get you, did I get you?
I don't know if SpongeBob wears long sleeves or not.
Actually he wears a shirt; he doesn't even have spots...
Wait.
^- Closing in on full coverage now.
^And then we'll get to the rendering of details.
- Yeah, same here.
- Yeah.
- Puttin' paintbrushes in paint, then on Clark's body.
(Beethoven's Für Elise)
- This side is giving me Picasso.
My work has no, has no meaning.
It can't be boxed.
You look like a techno merman.
- I've always loved the colors of Sailor Moon,
which is like blue, and pink, and yellow.
Sailor Moon meets Shape of Water.
Merperson.
^- I wonder if Face ID will still recognize my face.
^- Five minutes.
^I don't know if I'm gonna be able
^to complete my masterpiece,
but I'm gonna try really really hard.
I'm thinking about changing directions,
but I'm totally a pro, so.
- You've changed directions like, seven times, Jade!
Whoa, whoa, she's doing things.
^- I think that's when you start moving
really, really fast, so.
- Yep.
- I can't, I have to move not at all.
(upbeat piano music)
(Joy and Jade groaning)
- Clark, you have really nice skin.
- Thank you , I moisturize morning and night.
- [Producer] Five, four, three, two, one, done.
- Brush drop.
Whoa!
Oh my god!
Jade, yours isn't that bad!
I like it.
Wow.
- [Joy] So you're basically a space mermaid.
- I like it.
- [Joy] Don't think you're from this planet.
- So I'm gonna have to make a tough
choice, and say that I think the
overall winner is Joy, the space fish.
- And you did a great job for your first time,
like, it's always difficult, and it's especially
difficult to have your first time happen on camera.
- Man, I freaking sucked.
I was not prepared, I'm just like:
"Clark, paint, body, boom."
So I definitely understand now that
body painting is not as easy as it looks.
So I actually originally came in here with
the idea of paining a tiger, which is why
there's a lot of stripes, and then he was like:
"Oh, yes, theme's under the sea."
And I'm like: "Damn, there ain't no tigers under the sea."
(hinges squeaking)